[Musique]
bonjour gaël de clermont ferrand bonjour
- bientôt chargé de mission au sein du
prix de ces le plan régional déception
professionnelle des travailleurs
handicapés nous sommes en plein gaël de
carmentran dans cette semaine pour
l'emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap à 30 ans après la promulgation
de la première loi handicap et emploi
trente ans après il faut encore d'une
semaine pour sensibiliser autour de
cette problématique
eh bien oui effectivement coup d'envoi
hier de cette semaine pour l'emploi
c'est une semaine qui a lieu tous les
ans depuis plusieurs années puisqu'on en
est à la 21ème édition est effectivement
même si la situation progresse d'année
en année on voit qu'il y a des marges de
progression toujours devant nous et
surtout un travail encore d'information
de sensibilisation et la réalité de cet
emploi des personnes en situation de
handicap dans un pays on le rappelle
milliers par le chômage ou le marché
conomique ne tâtonne pas il est
carrément à l'arrêt alors d'abord il
faut dire que l'insertion de personnes
en situation de handicap dans l'emploi
est une vraie réalité au plan national
aujourd'hui en martinique c'est à dire
que des personnes travaillent
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
publiques et privées parce qu'il ya des
quotas parce qu'une législation
alors effectivement la législation a
beaucoup aidés en france il a été choisi
il ya une trentaine d'années avec cette
première loi handicap auquel vous
faisait référence d'imposer un quota
c'est à dire demandé à toutes les
entreprises d'atteindre un taux de 6% de
leurs employés en situation de handicap
ce quota pour inciter sensibiliser et
effectivement inséré dans nouvelles
personnes j'en arrive à ce 6% alors on
n'y arrive pas encore c'est pour ça que
je disais que les marges de progrès sont
encore devant nous on a fait beaucoup
on a fait beaucoup d'avancées
aujourd'hui on est alors au niveau
national à 3 3% de ce taux d'emploi et
en martinique à 22.7 en gros dans les
entreprises privées
d'où l'intérêt de ce genre de
manifestation comme cette semaine alors
qui doit être sensibilisé sur les
personnes en situation de handicap elles
mêmes sont les entreprises ce sont les
circuits économiques et sociaux alors
oui c'est l'ensemble en fait
de la société qui reste encore à
sensibiliser parce que on voit dans le
sur ce sujet du handicap encore beaucoup
de représentations à lever beaucoup de
stéréotypes
alors d'abord dans pour le grand public
pour le pour les employeurs pour qu'ils
le handicapé est souvent perçu encore de
manière j'allais dire très très
lacunaire et et pas dans toute son
l'expliqué savaria cette vision sa cause
du petit plano avec le fauteuil roulant
dans l'impression que toute personne
handicapée forcément fauteuil roulant
alors ça fait partie effectivement des
représentations bien souvent pour les
personnes encore le handicap moteur par
exemple et le fauteuil roulant
représente ce handicap alors que on a
coutume de dire que c'est moins de 2%
des personnes qui sont concernées par
par un handicap moteur donc on voit que
le champ est beaucoup plus vaste que ça
alors on aurait peut-être dû commencer
par la gueule carmantrand être en
situation de handicap ça sous-entend
quoi ça veut dire quoi exactement
alors là on parle de handicap dans
l'emploi ça veut dire qu'on se réfère à
la loi qui dit que on peut avoir une
reconnaissance de travailleur handicapé
une reconnaissance administrative à
partir du moment où on a une déficience
de plusieurs natures auditives visuelles
psychique mais également liée à une
maladie invalidante et que sais tu que
cette déficiente entraîne un certain
nombre d'incapacité dans le travail et
j'insiste là dessus parce que du coup ça
donne une définition extrêmement large
du sujet est beaucoup plus large que
ceux auxquels on pense bien souvent dans
le handicap visible en général une
personne malvoyante une personne
malentendante dans le handicap lourd
surtout et qui fait évidemment peur et
qui freinent le recrutement et les
employeurs alors qu'aujourd'hui
finalement on est dans une situation où
il ya toutes formes de handicap
de manière assez large et notamment par
exemple toutes ces maladies chroniques
sont visibles on y arrive dans quelques
secondes parce qu'il faut aussi préciser
que le handicap n'est pas forcément que
de naissances ce important
bien entendu il a aussi lourd
stéréotypes
on est handicapé c'est s'est largement
faux puisque en gros 15 % des personnes
ont un handicap de naissance ça veut
dire que 85 % de cette population aux
fêtes ont eu un accident
ou une maladie au cours de leur
existence au cours de leur vie
professionnelle
et là on voit que au delà même du sujet
d'intégrer d'insérer des personnes dans
l'emploi on a les normes sujet devant
nous du maintien dans l'emploi de
personnes qui vont comme vous et moi
aujourd'hui on travaille et qui vont un
jour être confrontés à une maladie
l'exemple du diabète puisqu'on en parle
cette semaine le diabète par exemple
peut être doit être considéré considérer
tout simplement commune une situation de
handicap
alors disons qu'il ya un champ
aujourd'hui des maladies qui sont dites
invalidante dont le diabète dont des
maladies chroniques la drépanocytose
aussi dont on parle beaucoup ici en
martinique dont d'autres formes de
maladies chroniques ou infectieuse qui
peuvent être considérés aujourd'hui et
qui peuvent être reconnus comme
handicapantes dans l'emploi et qui
peuvent donc donner lieu à cette
reconnaissance donc c'est important que
les gens effectivement et les gens qui
sont en emploi et qui ont ce type de
maladies et de problèmes de santé au
travail se manifeste parce que derrière
l'intérêt c'est justement de dépasser ce
handicap et cette stigmatisation puisque
ça offre derrière des aides des
aménagements je vais vous donner deux
trois exemples par exemple une personne
va pouvoir bénéficier d'un aménagement
d'horaires pour prendre ces traitements
par exemple ou pour quitter son emploi
temporairement pour tel ou tel protocole
d aménagement de poste une personne avec
une petite déficients par exemple visuel
va permettre d'avoir un écran réadapter
plus large et on voit bien que ça peut
être aussi un siège adapté pour le dos
par exemple j'ai cet exemple en tête de
cette personne qui est drépanocytaire et
qui travaillait chez pôle emploi et qui
a pu être totalement maintenu dans son
emploi
après voilà de longues années de maladie
de traitement juste avec un aménagement
de son poste un bureau amovible
effectivement le fauteuil comme vous
comme vous disiez une semaine de
sensibilisation donc en premier lieu à
destination des personnes en situation
de handicap parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
réticences pourquoi pourquoi ces
personnes ne veulent pas dire leur
employeur quelles sont en situation de
handicap
ces deux le regard des autres encore une
fois qu'il faut changer alors il ya
encore effectivement le regard des
autres le regard des collègues les
autres salariés qui vont peut-être
estimé que cette personne travaillera -
ou ne sera moins productives
il ya le regard de l'employeur qui fait
via donc de l'éducation à faire
également vis-à-vis des autres tout à
fait et encore beaucoup de pédagogie à
faire pour dire que d'abord c'est un
sujet qui nous concerne tous comme on le
disait que ça peut arriver à tout le
monde qu'il ya pour ça des aménagements
qu'aujourd'hui avec la l'allongement par
exemple delà de la vie professionnelle
ça devient un vrai sujet ça devient un
sujet de société ça devient un sujet
pour les entreprises y compris pour les
employeurs j'allais dire parce que c'est
aussi une façon de lutter contre
l'absentéisme contre les problématiques
de recrutement d'être en capacité de
prendre en compte ces questions de santé
au travail j'allais dire plus largement
alors après effectivement le terme
reconnaissance travailleurs handicapés
fait un peu peur on l'a vu c'est un
terme qui correspond à une
reconnaissance administrative mais sur
lequel voilà il faut voir au delà du de
la stigmatisation handicap la
possibilité de s'ouvrir des droits ou
des différents aménagements
alors justement gagner le quart à matran
si je me découvre aujourd'hui une
maladie je suis en situation de handicap
je vais voir mon patron pour lui dire
j'ai des protocoles observé il me faut
tel ou tel aménagement d'horaires ou des
espaces
si j'y suis refus catégorique de la part
de l'employeur que peut-il se passer là
où d'abord vous pouvez vous adresser à
votre médecin du travail
c'est lui qui va vous orienter faire en
sorte enfin vous expliquer effectivement
l'ensemble des démarches votre employeur
lui de fête sera obligé un peu de suivre
les recommandations du médecin du
travail donc c'est le médecin du travail
qui va permettre de canaliser un petit
peu votre situation et de et de décider
avec vous s'il ya des recommandations
des aménagements ou si vous êtes
effectivement dans le cas où une
orientation vers cette reconnaissance
travailleurs handicapés et pertinente et
auquel cas il vous enverra vers un
certain nombre d'organismes dont le
sameth qui s'occupe de ça qui est un
service de l'agefiph
et puis vous ferez ensuite le circuit
classique d'un dossier sur sur cette
reconnaissance du handicap et est-ce que
je m'expose à d'éventuelles sanctions de
mon employeur si par hasard je conteste
le fait qu'il n'aille pas assez vite
danse dans la compagnie d'accompagnement
qui devrait être le sien pour dans
l'évolution de la maladie
non je crois qu'aujourd'hui comme on le
disait les mentalités évoluent et les
chefs d'entreprise prennent de plus en
plus à coeur cette question de santé au
travail et on le sait la difficulté
aujourd'hui de recruter de trouver et
des personnes compétentes fait que voilà
le le chef d'entreprise a aussi tout
intérêt à accompagner ces personnes dans
un système encore une fois aménagé qui
va lui permettre lui aussi de maintenir
son activité sa productivité
il a aussi intérêt à mener une vraie
politique de handicap et de
sensibilisation en interne à son
entreprise et certaines entreprises ont
des politiques vraiment dynamique en ce
sens pour justement sensibiliser
l'ensemble du corps des salariés alors
peut-être une autre idée préconçue de se
dire que la personne en situation de
handicap qui est embauché dans une
entreprise cette personne sera plus
productif car elle voudra faire ses
preuves et du coup ce n'est pas une
pression qu'on lui met sur les épaules
alors les enquêtes employeurs nous dise
effectivement que le taux de
satisfaction est excellent et c'est
plutôt j'allais dire ça vient plutôt
court circuiter une idée reçue comme
quoi ces complexes sont des personnes
qui vont être très absente qui vont
avoir des difficultés d'adaptation et
c'est au contraire on line ou dans
certaines enquêtes et la dernière
enquête ipsos auprès des entreprises ne
le redis encore ce sont des personnes
qui effectivement sont extrêmement
motivés on l imagine quoi plus on s'est
battu et on a on connaît un petit peu le
parcours du combattant pour avoir cet
emploi et ces personnes donc son
souhaite garder cet emploi et donc sont
extrêmement motivés au travail et à
coeur d'assurer toute cette productivité
merci d'avoir été sur l'autre avec nogal
de karma tron rappelle que vous êtes
chargé de mission au sein du prix de ces
le plan régional de section
professionnelle des travailleurs
handicapés et nous sommes en plein dans
cette semaine pour l'emploi de ces
personnes en situation de handicap bonne
journée
[Musique]